[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic welcome back to what is the
final round of the 2019 fall chefs
classic as always we are your hosts my
name is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by
the wonderful Grandmaster then for
having me
yeah and there's actually a lot to be
decided still today of course in group a
we had to congratulate ray Robson as of
yesterday he was unassailable coming
into today's round and that gap is only
widened actually but in the B group
rising there there are no fewer than
five players who can walk away with the
championship coming into today so
definitely a lot to be decided a lot to
look out for today but why don't we take
a look at where we currently stand in
Group A Ray Robson of course drew his
round eight game and walked away with
six out of eight a full point and a half
ahead of his nearest competitor
astounding result and yeah it's just
incredible winning five games in a row
in the middle of the tournament a result
nobody can argue with it deserves first
place you wouldn't been forced drew his
round eight as well he was the only
player capable of catching ray going
into that round but with just a draw not
going to be enough Alexander Linderman
Darras roots front mokume Ian Elias
mirin and Verico bian are all sitting on
four out of eight hoping to turn this
tournament into a positive score in this
final round and why don't we take a look
at the B group now so this is where it's
really interesting
Yassir Quesada Perez is on five and a
half points out of eight in clear first
place going into today however they're
very serious chances for both Jack
Shambu lyac and Iran poco bian to score
a full point today and possibly tie yes
sir unless he manages to win his game as
well also some outside chances for
Manuel Petrossian and
scud rich absolutely both on
four-and-a-half are out of eight a very
respectable score plus one in this
tournament is is very nice very nice
they are mathematically not out yes
although it's it seems unlikely bug
unlikely yeah
math says it's still possible it is
possible all right and why don't we take
a look at the format for the tournament
today is of course the final day of to
ten play around Robyn's that is the a
group and the B group the time control
that they all played is ninety minutes
for the first forty moves with thirty
minutes added on for the remainder of
the game there is also a thirty second
increment from move one so these players
should never get too low on time in
these time scrambles they always have
this option to play a move get 30
seconds on the clock and start to build
up that time back breathe a little bit
make them a little breath and then it
can make another move yes yet again the
stress never stops
no but never stops there's also a draw
offer rule in effect the players are not
allowed to offer each other a draw until
black makes this thirtieth move and then
relevant to the day we actually have the
tiebreak format there are going to be it
depending on whether two players are
tied or a three or more there are a
couple different formats we could have
if there are just two players tied for
the lead
there will be a two game rapid batch
that is game in ten minutes with a two
second delay and then if they are still
tied after that the game is decided by
Armageddon and of course the Armageddon
game is a very special type of chess
where white gets extra time game in five
minutes with a two second increment
however black while he does have less
time he also has draw so in the
Armageddon match black only needs to
draw the game to be declared the fall
chess Classic champion wealth siding
stuff yeah hopefully we see some
exciting playoffs today it's possible
that some of these players might just
run away home with a clear first which
would also be interesting to see as well
as always we'd like to thank you for
joining us on
social media watching along in the
YouTube chat we love to answer your
questions how are you guys doing today
supernova you've been here like every
day good to see you back pal Ted 1 Sean
Lynch good to see you all here in the
chat room we love talking to you guys
and answering your questions also feel
free to join us on Twitter using the
hashtag fall chess classic and lastly if
you want to follow along watch the games
yourself you can do so at us chess
champs and calm that's where all these
games are being streamed you can watch
them live for yourself well Dennis what
are you expecting today looks like a lot
of action in the beaker I didn't know
what to expect today yeah in fact I was
in mid streaming in my own channel when
as all of you know I'm on Hamilton is
playing the B group of course and I
heard from their chat as they rated me
that he forfeited along with the player
in the a group yeah definitely
unexpected a turn of events here in fact
why don't we take a look at the pairings
in the a group and see what has happened
rotten all kuhnian is paired against
Alexander Bortnick Duras roots squares
off against the sieve der by Lee Ilyas
Marin takes on Alexander Lenderman and
Varco bian plays Alexander epitaphs and
then and what was going to be our key
matchup of the day between yordan event
forest and ray Robson that is the group
a leader in second place coming into
today the disaster is actually struck
here yeah Jordan was unfortunately very
late to the rounds and after 30 minutes
of being late the player has actually
forfeited and that's exactly what
happened to your dad a which is very
unfortunate for him coming in with clear
second place to today after this loss
it's looking like he's going to hope for
third at best and probably even lower
them more than that
so from second to third to possibly even
fifth or six yeah there's a big
heartbreak that he was playing good
solid chess it is really he was about to
play white as well yeah white against
Ray Robson definitely he would have been
looking to have kind of a moral victory
to end the turn
yes you're a walked away with the
championship that but if he could be
trained in the last round then that
would have been very very interesting
for you Orden why don't we take a look
at what happened in the B group however
as you mentioned Denish a similar thing
actually happened in the B group and
that is in the game between Aman
Hamilton and Manuel Petrosyan Amman
actually also missed the round today so
he will also be forfeited to Manuel
other than that though Alexander fear is
taking on a better Gregorian Denis CAD
rich takes on a rhombic Obion Viktor
Mikhailovsky takes on Jackson buyuk and
in our key matchup of the day yeah
circus out of Perez is parrot against
Steven Zurich of course Yassir is
playing to secure us a clear first place
in round 9 here with a win he would do
it he would be the champion with a draw
he is at least guaranteed to go into
those tie breaks and as far as I can see
he's actually going in the right
direction yeah wonderful secured his
first place Yeah right there yet but
very close it seems as though we have an
endgame here so what's going on Dennis
let's take a look and here we are
so interestingly black played rugby 5
which I'm not sure I like and don't even
quite understand because if you're down
some pawns especially a passer right you
really don't want to exchange the rooks
yeah I mean there's the saying I'll
reckon games are drawn wrong and that's
because rooks are actually very good at
stopping past pause rather rook a or
something I do understand that this pawn
is in constant danger but I feel that
rook b5 is admitting defeat as I don't
really see how black will survive this
endgame yeah and white simply trades off
the rooks and now there are a few things
that we can do here maybe the most
powerful of all is that I've as possible
maybe see what I'm considering is I want
to actually just build a wall with my
mom's and my knights and I think I can
achieve that if I play C 4 and then I
guess I don't know Bishop a6 makes the
most sense
and now c5 and I simply want to put this
night on b4 so Knight d5 check King e6
Knight B or King these have a night
before and now there's simply no path
for your king in I can bring my king up
the board at my leisure and it this just
looks to be winning to my eyes I can
only agree with you I think this is just
hopeless for black yeah I can try to the
pawn but then the e pawn will be lost
because the knight will easily block
these key squares especially on dark
squares where the white bishop can't
help at all right light squared Bishop
can't help at all
and I think this is just going to be a
clean victory and possibly a big one for
Yasser Quezada yeah once again if he
wins this game he clinches the
championship no one will be able to
catch him and this is a very nice like
construction of the white piece I think
all the knight in the pawns all in the
dark squares and together they
completely box out this king they
control every square on the Queen side
that the King might use to uh invade and
attack
phonce and actually I really like your
technical way of playing here Caleb
because you didn't look for like an
immediate win but you went for the
technical solution making sure that the
game is in no danger of ever messing it
up
I appreciate that Dennis thank you for
the compliment well I believe our
tournament champion ray Robson might be
ready to come in for an interview so why
don't we get him in here and you can
talk to him a little bit about his
outstanding tournament and not just his
recent game yes this recent game that
maybe didn't happen so while we were
waiting for him I want to take a look at
the other critical game between Cod rich
and Jaco bian want to back up a little
bit and go into this typical Italian
position Nagi for rook f1 engage 8 now
this is a very important game for both
players as coverage has the chance to
catch up with both Akopian
and many of the leaders and has a
mathematical chance of going for the
tiebreaks he had the neck next move
played here g4 is I think way too
exciting and well even ask my guest here
very soon but he thinks about this
fabulous move of g4 in fact Hagopian
said okay you can do that but I'll just
waltz around your pawn and plunk that
night on f4 97 Knight h2 96 and voila
the night arrives at the juicy square
and we have our special guest champion
ray Robson nice to be here so first off
I wanted to ask you about what do you
think about this move g4 I like the move
g4 in chess I don't know if I like g4 in
this position I don't think
doesn't look like white really has much
of an attack going even after g4 and of
course white weekend a lot of squares in
front of him his King George II for I
actually had looked at the game briefly
online even Knight takes d4 might be an
idea HG for Bishop g4 and f5 coming very
quickly and all of a sudden it's black
and white yeah so when is g4 good then
if this is not the moment what's it's
usually good when you're Castle Queen
side because then you don't have to
worry about your King if your castle Don
the same side of your both Castle
kingside
it's good if you have pieces ready to
attack also probably it's much safer if
the center was more close for example if
like in a royal Lopez structure or white
its d3 pawn beyond d5 black c7 pawn on
c5 then the center is more or less
closed and I can try to attack on the
king side here either side can still
open up the center black and still try
to break with d5 also blacks Knight is
not an f6 King is already on h8 so black
is more well prepared to push his F pawn
so it's yeah in this case it's really
not a favorable time to play g4 for
waiting so now we know when we should be
playing G 4 so in any case he had a
fantastic tournament but did you expect
these turn of events in the last round
what happened I did not expect that turn
of events what happened was I mean the
game was at 11 two hours earlier than
normal so I showed up like one or two
minutes late and I was expecting my
opponent to be there and having made the
first move but instead he wasn't there
so his clock was automatically started
and I was already strange because I
think he was normally there on time
every game but I figured he's probably
gonna be a few minutes late then then he
still hadn't shown up so I was starting
to wonder what was happening and yes
Tony about it with a few minutes before
there's like a thirty minute
yeah 30 minute forfeit time so I asked
him you know if they've been in contact
with him at all they said they tried to
call him I think but yet an answered so
yeah he he showed up like 1 minute after
30 minutes those up and yeah he said he
thought the game was at 12 instead of at
11 and so it's just unfortunate um I
don't even know if we could have like
continued the game 3-1 I think it was
just an automatic yeah it's an automatic
forfeit as far as I know
make sure it's interesting because the
4/5 times I'm used to as one o'clock and
not thirty minutes but maybe Tony rich
knows the specifics about that and maybe
it was also part I know in the country
this is 30 minutes yeah so a surprising
turn of events and it's kind of sad
because not just in the a group but also
in the B group I'm on Hambleton also
forfeited exactly the same way yeah so
but let's talk about positive stuff
first off you started rather slowly in
this tournament and then you lost the
game against daro sweats how did you
recuperate after that loss what went
through your head after that loss if we
can go I wouldn't say I mean the after I
lost to him then it was a slow start
before that that was the second round
already so the first game I drew with
black against bortnik which was okay
mm-hmm and then yeah I was white against
Darwish and of course I I was hoping to
win but I know he's very good player I
think he plays similarly to me actually
tries to play very correctly not get
worse positions and that's why he didn't
that game he was a lot of time but he he
played very accurately so he he was
never really worse and in that game yeah
at some point I I didn't actually over
press I knew I wasn't better and the
position should be equal but I one move
of his and I'm still equal but the
position changed from being
me having no losing chances to me having
some potential danger and I kind of I
made if I got worried and I made a few
more bad news after that and he just let
me interject right there did you think
about not exchanging your bishop on f6
in that game because I felt that later
on that was kind of the reason you got
into some danger because you did give
away the bishop there or you didn't feel
that was that dangerous in that moment I
as far as I remember I thought a lot
about that move yeah there were lots of
options there I was trying to fight for
an advantage of course but I couldn't
find one and I think there are probably
many moves that could have made which
would have been equal including what I
did I did realize I mean there's some
potential danger with the bishop pair so
I had I had evaluated that but what I
thought I could do is I always in that
game I had a knight and Bishop he had
two bishops but I could play a Knight to
f4 at some point forcing him to either
give me one of his bishops or I'd
captured the other bishop and it would
still be equal so my evaluation that it
was still equal there was correct I just
didn't make that move in time and then
when he played f5 now his bishop was
kind of already escaping and then I
already had to be accurate still had to
play that move and exchange bishops and
instead of a knight for Bishop I have to
exchange bishops but it would still be
close to equal instead I let him keep
the bishop and then it was already
unpleasant for me so after that game who
did you play and how did you reassess
your situation well I was very upset
after the game because I mean not just
because I lost the way I lost lost with
white in a position where I really
shouldn't have been risking anything and
I lost that way several times in these
events I feel like I lost
iliyan is Nick with with white where he
played the Petroff I lost yeah several
games with white where I just what did
you do different after that game yeah I
mean I I streamed about the game I
analyzed it I mean the
I was probably I mean wasn't a bad way
just to be able to interact with people
about the game and not just be in my own
thoughts not just fuming on your own
about that game look human with other
people you may give a lot of people so I
also wanted to ask what is next for you
professionally what is your next goal MA
well my next my next goal is I mean it's
still been my goal is 2,700 but in my
next term is I love man I love man yeah
and what do you expect from yourself
they're like roughly I mean I don't
expect anything like this I think if I'm
able to play the same level then I will
keep keep going up but I mean I think
the level I'm playing at is around I
mean high 2600 close to 2,700 maybe like
26 8090 in that range when I'm playing
normally well but it's just a question
of whether I can maintain that because
obviously I've been that rating before
I've been up to 26 80 but then somehow
I've had a few setbacks every time and
I'm getting close to that again but
we'll see I need to have a few good
tournaments in a row like I came into
this tournament my last term it being
the World Open where I felt it was a
good event even though my rating didn't
really change so I've had two positive
events but I'm hoping to keep keep on
going so congratulations and I can see
that you're very cautiously optimistic
about your upcoming event but I wish all
the best for you and good luck at the
Isle of Man congratulations
Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
huge congratulations to ray rats on the
on an outstanding event and he may be
cautiously optimistic but I am very much
looking forward to seeing what he does
in this next tournament yeah it's going
to be quite well having five events
consecutively in this level that that
should boost your confidence for the
next event it certainly shows a deeper
level of understanding more accurate
more technical play than his peers in
this event well we saw there with Ray
Robson winning the event he walks away
with a grand prize of six thousand
dollars why don't we take a closer look
at our prize funds in both pools as this
tournament comes to a close yet but
first of all how was yesterday in this
end game yes sir actually reached the
position that we discussed but he didn't
actually play your plan yet the c4 c5
and night b4 maneuver I think he is
contemplating whether he should go for
the win immediately with 95 trying to
promote this spawn or if he should do
the slow way that's right suggested
there's also another option of you know
instead of trying to build this barrier
you can just play king d to get your
king in the game yeah it's just
technically winning so it does seem that
Quezada has his faith in his own hands
yeah a fantastic position to be in and
if you're kicked out of just a little
bit on the psychology side are you
looking at a round pick OB ins game are
you looking at Jackson Bulli x game or
are you just sitting at the board as he
is focusing on your technical team
should definitely look at your own game
yes because any distraction just gives
more chances to myself understandable
well once again let's see what these
players are playing for with the prize
fund in Group A Ray Robson walked away
with that grand prize of six thousand
dollars no small payday for him or any
of these players really there's a very
generous prize fund of $22,000 total the
second place prize in Group A is four
thousand dollars that is what those
players are really competing for now
those myriad of players all on four out
of eight with just one win they would be
able to take home that prize of course
third place is three thousand for this
two thousand and and so on in a group
talking about players trying to get
closer to that four thousand dollars yes
well we have a game between Ilyas myrin
and Alex Slenderman yeah we'll take a
look in just a second but why don't we
also take a quick look at the prize
funds in the B group they are planning
for a first-place prize of $4,000 that
is what yeah circus not a Perez is
hoping to walk away with with clear
first today
second place is 2500 third place 2,000
fourth place 1500 and fifth $1,000 no
small chump change at these st. louis
tournaments but all right which game do
you want to check out the Ilyas myrin
Alex Slenderman which is actually going
to and pretty soon as yes why does play
b7 but then we will not wait till white
goes Bishop b6 certainly not just take
it has happened in the game b7 rook
takes b7 and unfortunately for Ilyas
myrin these pawns are just way too fast
yes those those connected pastors are
just too fast and you can also just
bring the kink closer and stop this King
from coming back it's rather unfortunate
how the white king just gets kind of
boxed out it'd be an interesting endgame
if white had a rook instead of a bishop
but unfortunately bishops not quite as
good as those rugs at stopping this this
one formation big win for Alex
thunderman as he's guaranteed shared
second place after he wins yes this
brings him to five out of nine for the
tournament on the hole which is actually
just plus one but that's enough no other
player managed to go +1 yet with a
strong field like this this is a
respectable result by Alex Slenderman
if he manages to win this game another
player hoping for that they're their
piece of the pie with second place is
Doris weirds the man ray raphson
mentioned I actually managed to take him
down in the second round he has quite a
nice position I think against Nassif
Durr by Lee here and again we can take a
quick look at body language of the two
players right just look how Darwin
sweats is in full concentration mode
trying to find the killer blow while the
rabidly seems to be a bit more reluctant
about his chances yeah I don't know
everybody everybody leaning in it seems
like this is really a critical moment
here what's going on on the board so
there's some big pressure on the f7 pawn
and it's never good news if you're black
big pressure like pressure and also the
h6 bond is weak on the positive side for
black he does have an unopposed Bishop
on b7 and maybe some Knight f3 ideas in
the future right but some any yeah white
openings would lead to disaster for
black though yeah material is even white
hasn't had to sacrifice anything to get
this what looks to be very almost
devastating attack so it's looking very
good for white how does black solve all
these problems is there a way you can
stop white from opening up on the f7
square and also taking these aged six
out of six is potentially the best as
you can't really take because that would
just be the end right with so many
threats and there's this potential
discovery it's just going to be lost and
of course the problem with a move like
King g7 would simply be e takes F any a
nine and five o night of five as well
I'm sorry in fact White has more than
two threats
he has like four threats taking on h8
six taking on f7 and Knight f5 one two
three
we've seen the triple-threat yes that's
a quadruple threat the quadruple threat
disaster
nothing can stop a quadruple threat so
perhaps like you said best for black
would be to play this move f6 when I
guess you can't actually take on h6 due
to rick h7 trapping the queen but
thankfully we have a couple more of
those threats to rely on and a move like
Knight f5 might be quite good yes
in fact our body decided that there's
just too much pressure on his position
and took on e6
as I mentioned before looks very
dangerous for black yeah I guess see
tonight take c6
he must just be planning to sacrifice
this exchange I don't see how else black
universe hoping maybe that there's some
counter tricks but it does seem that
whites attack seems to be more real than
I'm definitely on board blacks after
route takes e6 in fact I don't think we
actually have to take that rook we can
play a very nice move Queen takes h6
piling up on that pinned piece and like
really doesn't have enough attackers the
Queen would be if the Queen would be on
f7 then there would be a raging attack
but that's two moves away from heaven
yes and heaven is much closer for white
this time as Bishop takes c6 it will be
decisive looking very good for Doris
routes so perhaps these are two players
who are hoping to make their way into
that shared second place position
however more interesting I guess is this
B group so we know that yessir has a
good position but let's say for example
that somehow something goes wrong he
doesn't manage to convert this then it's
time to be looking at these last two
games between a rhombic Obion and Denis
CAD rich and Jackson buuck and Viktor
Michalowski if either jack or aram
Akopian win their game and Yassir draws
then that's when we get these playoffs
so here we see a rhombic Obion and Denis
CAD rich deep in their in their battle
here this is of course that came where
does played the kind of weird g4 move
and how was a ROM taking advantage of it
so Aram actually made sure to bring this
night into passivity and as we can see
in this position he succeeded as its
only job of this night is to defend
these pawns is miserable leaving before
you want this night on f5 if it's
possible but it's not and you can see
that white is suffering the consequences
of these early pawn pushes right and
after like a potential Knight e5 move
it's very hard to make any active plans
for white yes this rook is active on a 8
but by in itself it's not strong enough
to conjure up real threats and I mean
it's it's as they said the pawns do not
move backwards yes hey there how much
you want them to White's best move by
far I think would be to play pawn g4 to
g3 but it's not allowed so that g2 would
be even better
g2 would be even better so I do expect
Hawk Obiang to have great meaning
chances here especially maybe with ideas
of maybe either going to e5 as I did
before or b6 and c4 c3 creating a second
front because at the moment CAD rich is
worse but is still holding on yeah he's
he's defending but he is defending well
for the moment but this of course is
really going to put the pressure on
Yassir Quesada Perez he knows that Aram
Maccabean is going to be coming for him
unless he manages to it to win this
endgame so let's take a look at the
sheet and bully out game seconds for the
jack the other player who is capable of
catching yes or casada Perez in first
place and it seems that Shambo leoch has
a decent position here as he neutralized
the bishop pair of Myka Lipsky as his
bishop stares at this f8 square but
nobody is there to be attacked right and
all these big diagonals that would be
perfect are closed down by me huh laughs
keys own pawns on c3 c4 and g3 so that
would mean that black is doing okay
which is probably true
yeah maybe white does have a threat or
two here yeah why does have pressure on
these pawns yes and potential invasions
but if black manages to keep keep it all
together
black will have some chances because of
the structure
yeah absolutely so definitely a lot of
chests left to be played in this game
it's a little unclear to me at the
moment who actually stands better here
but so it'll be interesting to see what
these players come up with probably it
is slightly better because of the
bishops and some pressure from makovski
but Stamboul iakh has this long-term
chance of playing against these
potential huge weaknesses yet there's
this for there's this dynamic between
you know white and having some more
active pieces yes but like having a
better structure so if white can't do
anything with that activity and then it
will in fact be black who stands a
better chance of making something out of
this game yes so let's go back for a
second to the Quezada 0th game as it's
critical of course everything is riding
on this match if yessir wins he is
champion and as we can see he's
listening to mr. Caleb Denby I love it
when they listen to me except when they
listen to me and then things go poorly
then I just feel bad but yes indeed it
seems that he chose to go for the
critical but slow and positional way of
winning yes just stopping black from
having any real counter play I suspected
he might go for this not because it's
the fastest way to win or maybe even the
best way to win but it is the meanest
way to win yes you just cut off that
king completely completely your opponent
feels very bad about him about himself
you know as oh my king can't go in
anywhere what am I supposed to do just
move back and forth and then you get to
sit back and relax
say yes I will win this in my own time
also nice c7 is a huge threat as well so
if you medium wants to cash in early he
might as the a pawn can also start
running
apart from night before I see so I'm the
concrete way also the concrete adjuster
works yes so it's very interesting as
Quezada just like way Robson did a big
streak in the middle and caught up with
Jackson bull yaku yeah it started three
out of three yeah three out of three a
great way to start the tournament but
unfortunately for Jack he could not
maintain that that type of results yes
and yes sir coming out of kind of kind
of nowhere he just simply kept winning
and winning and winning and now here he
stands atop the leaderboard so just to
show this line if the bishop were to
capture on c4 the white knight jumps
into c7 controlling the two key light
squares of a six and a eight and now
probably there's nothing better for
black than to try to bring the king in
but it's all far too slow bishop yeah
and and you Queen and blacks other
option is to bring the bishop in to say
e4 to try to stop this pawn but after a
seven Bishop c4 a eight Queen white is
simply going to be up a piece you were
not in time to trap my knight in the
corner I will escape and I will win just
to point out a fine little trick if
black were to have one extra tempo yes
he could potentially trap that night
with king c6 although maybe this is
still winning this is still winning but
it's something to remember that even a
king by itself can trap a cornered night
Knights in the corner not ideal yet
ideal so yeah looking very good for yes
sir I mean the lines all seem to
concretely just just work out I don't
think there's even any way to to really
keep this game going for let's take a
look at the players what's going on
there is Eric ready to get it in or is
he still pondering if he can find a
proper defense
we see yes sir walking around the room
they're just taking his time sipping his
water he seems to be enjoying himself
and the bishop takes c4 that happen so
but you will soon see
Quezada go for 9797 played there's
really not too much to calculate here
it's a very straightforward line not too
many branches for black at all
you simply Queen the pawn and have an
extra night to boot yes
Bishop d3 played and we are heading to
the end of this game as yasser Quezada
Paris is inching closer with every move
yes for the title yeah and I think we
should probably just stay on this yes we
should because I can't imagine this is
going to last I think this will have
much longer he's soon so Steven does
reroute this Bishop to e4 hoping to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn but of
course
Knights are better than no Knights yes
you rather want to have an extra night
then no not at all
interesting so Quezada actually plays
King f2 which is change but o f2 by
disciplic decided that a7 and a8 is
unstoppable and there we have it
yeah he has the B group champion it's
all over asada yes a winning the B group
outright with an astounding score of no
less than six and a half out of nine a
very strong score I'm trying to do the
math in my head I believe that's plus
four is it not yes yes plus four and a 9
round event is a very excellent score of
course we can't tell betray Robson
winning five games in a row in the
middle of the match so plus four we will
have to do a little very respectable
hopefully we're going to have a little
chat with him as the B group champion
and yet yes there with one s snuck a - s
yes sir that's does commentary here
sometimes walks away with the
first-place prize of four thousand
dollars of course we will try to get him
in for an interview but it might take a
couple minutes as these players do enjoy
analyzing their games sometimes and
everybody deserves a little bit of
celebration of their own of course of
course
so does Yasser Quezada so well with that
and the beet group champion is decided
but what isn't decided is the
second-place prize in the eight group so
we looked at a little bit at da Rose
game who's fighting for it a little bit
at Lenderman game who's fighting for it
but we have not yet seen a cobia normal
kuhnian both of which are also looking
to move to five out of nine and a
portion of that second-place prize so
let's take a look at the demo Kumi on
bortnik game which looks like a pleasant
position for a white yet I think the
only way for a white to break through is
f4 but it's for some reason I don't feel
it's likely that mine is going to win
this game well yeah and another problem
is if you don't play f4 right now
then perhaps black can actually play f4
yes and if that happens then all the
files are locked the only way you're
breaking through is if you give up a
full piece for for a couple pawns
somewhere yes it's not that Malcolm yan
can't push just like Ray Robson did
against
Varro Cobian right but there's a big
chance that the position will be just
locked down and drawn alright so not
looking too promising for on--then and
how about vara Cobian what's going on in
his game so Barr has a firm grip on the
position as he managed to block blacks
Bishop which had to move to f8 to find
some targets right and
both sides seem to have a few natural
moves left to play white of course would
love to play this move h5 loosening up
softening up those light squares with
this h7 g 6 f7 complex and then
following that if the H file were to
open white could very naturally bring
the pieces to the H file the problem
with that of course is that your
opponent gets to make moves in chess as
well so things are not always so easy
and black is going to be looking for
some sacrifices with Bishop takes a
three as well as some pawn breaks with a
move like pawn to b4 in some cases just
to take a look at this one White has
some very nice defensive ideas and also
after Knight B for whites position does
look safe enough yeah white well black
does have this a3 square for his pieces
white is doing a good job here
controlling a one controlling a to
controlling B 3 and B 4 and B 2 there's
just not enough squares for blacks
making a dagger so it does feel that
this position is slightly better for
white especially that this Bishop is
just totally bad staring at pawns
apart from defending doing not much but
even considered like moves Knight B for
such as night before just to exchange
this night for this Bishop and then the
difference between this aggressive
Bishop and this dumb Bishop will be
apparent yeah definitely this Bishop on
c6 really the problem piece is the black
piece or a pot off
so with that of Mines looking promise
for daro Lenderman
and a Cobian perhaps we will have three
players sharing in fact second Lenderman
has won his game oh yes
the game and the chance would be happy
to have him yeah definitely very nice we
talked against Ilyas myrin with those
three passed pawns on the Kings side
proving dominant over that Bishop and in
fact in the Malcolm iam bortnik game f4
was played Bishop f2 and we can see that
White's
only hope now is to either sacrifice the
bishop for some pawns or some c5 break
but to be honest I'm skeptical neither
of those look very promising to me
either
and to be honest I feel this is going to
be Oh a Lenderman is still playing
because we spoke a bit too soon but of
course this end game totally winning
film is extremely winning what actually
kind of made me confuse that as a black
win that in many dgt boards and ever you
have a black king in the center that
signals a win for black yes of course on
the dgt boards once the game ends the
arbiter or the players move the players
to those central squares two kings on
two light squares means a white win
Kings on black squares means a black win
and Kings on e4 and e5 opposing each
other means a game was a draw but yet we
see the king is actually just on e5 in
this case and after Bishop d6 probably
this King is heading to e4 after which
you can very nicely support that pawn
Pro those pawn pushes from a central
outpost turns out even Kings like being
in the center sometimes yes and to be
honest I assume that this game will end
early shortly right
these players of course they know what's
going on here so let's take a look at
the other critical game between da TOS
where it's ended I believe a thief
absolutely it looks like white did in
fact end up taking this rook off of
e6000 the weaker King and the less
developed rook it's it's not looking
good yes it does seem that next to
Lenderman switch is going to be another
person tying for second place
definitely so we left it at queen 8 6 9
f3 we actually looked at this one king
f2 they dreamed of having this Queen on
f7 yes but and it wasn't true we
realized that's not reality
my d4 takes King back because you don't
want to get checked and you don't want
the Queen
to come to answer me the Tempe I agree
so king g1 is a strong logical move move
that way actually mentioned that spirits
is famous for being very correct and
trying to find the best possible moves
in the position King G 1 is just that
kind of move Bishop c8 and has a move
like Queen d5 hitting the rook and
eventually getting the rooks in the game
it's getting more and more likely that
Sirius is going to win soon yeah and all
right unfortunately I think I've heard
we were unable to get Yassir in for an
interview I'm not the best Spanish
speaker myself finish I don't know if
you are but yes or not supremely
confident in his English skills luckily
for him he has all the chest skills to
make up for it yes he will walk away
with that championship prize of $4,000
in the B group and as well as the honor
the respect the bragging rights of the
title of a fall chess Classic champion
and also to his credit he did lose the
all-important match when he faced
Stamboul iakh yes and he still managed
to win the whole tournament outright
which shows real character yeah many
times people after losing a key game
they would give up on a tournament but
not yet sir Quezada yeah both ray and
yes sir showing their ability to really
bounce back after a tough game or a
tough couple of games well okay so
things looking good for daro things
looking good for lunderman things
looking pretty okay for vara Cobian and
that seems to be where we're standing in
the a group meanwhile in the B group
around poco bian is still trying to
convert this position against Dennis
cabbage not too much progress there but
there has been progress in the Michal
EPS quiche temple yeah yes that's what I
was about to mention things seem to be
changing we think alike Caleb we think
alike so what I find very interesting
that it turns out that stamboli ox
gambit of playing this opening this
risky opening didn't turn out as
favorable as he wanted it to be
interesting because I feel that yes not
that black
can't go rook d3 and hope for taking
lots of funds but I'd start to be scared
of this pawn and the H file yeah that
puns far away from your knight in your
case so uh if you really can't stop it
then you're gonna have some issues yes
and yes black might be able to stop it
but then white might have constant
pressure and the Damocles sword threat
of playing age 7 h8 at any moment yes
these these types of end games I've
always found just terrifying yes
you know maybe objectively okay I can
take enough pawns I have enough threats
on the other side but there's always
this nagging sense of doom where it's
like oh one bad move and my opponent
gets a queen and then it's over
and if we've been perusing nonverbals
before let's do it this time as well
let's take a look at the players oh yes
and how are the players feeling jack
really leaning in kind of kind of
focusing here either
head and hands not also deep in
concentration yes and it's also very
interesting that if you look at the
times we collapse key has two minutes
then Bullock has 12 yeah so that's a
positive for temple yeah
yes it is but um there's a couple ways
to get into time pressure one is your
position is bad and you're struggling
really hard to defense and I don't think
that's the case here I think Viktor
really liked his position and he was
just trying to get the absolute utmost
that he could out of it and that's not a
bad reason to find yourself in time
pressure is it you've gotten yourself a
good position yeah I honestly agree with
you Caleb because it's not the hardest
task to start pushing the h-bond rights
like a madman
Victor's already done the work he's
gotten the good position now it's time
to cash in just you know almost pre move
I will play h5 I will play h6 penwick
knows it's duty he'll start marching for
various goals Heinrich now you deal with
it yes so on the other hand I do have to
revisit if stamboli AK has some hope
here well yes maybe a little bit
okay if he manages to some house of that
h-bomb right Annie pond yeah he does
have an e pawn that might be able to
roam down and have a technically winning
position if lucky especially as
McAuliffe skis under 2-minutes or around
two minutes right there's some hope for
him to win this game well let's look at
some specifics okay let's turn here I
think rook d3 does make the nuisance and
then what is white going to do simply
push this pawn to h5 or take the time
out of his day to try to defend this C
pawn somehow well if you love Henrik so
let's put him into work all right I
agree of course it's black I'm going to
take off all your pawns so I will start
with the check your King moose I'll take
on g3 well let's push it all right and
now I must play rook h3 or else I am
risking quite a lot here so there's two
things that Mike can do so why can't
start pushing and then try to put this
bishop to have six and then promote that
but it can be a bit looking at that line
I wasn't really convinced of it I think
I actually have some kind of strange
moves if he played Bishop e7 or yet so
h7 first and now I think just don't move
like king d5 might be very powerful and
your one thing to bring the Kings over
to ISA yeah I'm stopping Bishop e7 for
the moment and yeah I don't know I don't
and now white would actually be stuck as
there is no good way of helping this
pawn to promote yeah after remove like
rook g7 actually all of the white pieces
seems to be fairly a mobile yes but some
so probably me collapse key can't really
do that okay where has to really
consider if h7 is that good or not yeah
I maybe just take the pawn I was
expecting him to just yet use this trick
a little bit to his advantage and now as
white you know I'm so mad at my opponent
for putting his H pawn on h6 I want to
put my e pawn on E
and see how he likes it yes it's simply
four and now we kind of see yes
White's past pawn is a little bit
farther away it seems to be a little bit
more dangerous but this epon will give
black some very nice counter play okay
so eight seven let's push it
I guess you push it this way I'll play
III I guess I want to stop you and the
Lenderman game is over
as Alex Slenderman the wins and is
sharing second place yes Willie we will
hear more from him absolutely we'd love
to get game and yeah Tullius Mirren and
talk about his game talking about his
tournament as a whole as well he's
played some very interesting chess and
actually this Bishop before that we just
played we can't pinpoint that that's why
bishops are so much better than Knights
in these open positions as I'm
threatening to push this pawn as well as
defending this key square of e1 yeah
Bishop's go far yes that being said
black is not in big danger right but
it's not that white is risking losing
either yeah I I agree here so looking to
be a draw yeah a balanced position of
course this was just one line but these
are very logical moves very natural
moves for the players white really is
going to have to bank on this H pawn and
then black has to find coach place
somehow somehow why not by pushing his
own EEP on up the board okay so not
looking like jack is going to be able to
make anything out of that position what
is going on
with iram huh Cobian not much he did
improve his position since then yeah man
95 95 and this is kind of a logical
technical play you're trying to get rid
of your opponent's only active piece of
course b7 takes takes a3 a3 I'm not sure
but probably kid rich is still hoping
that something funky will happen in this
game so why
go a three-bean b8 but obviously Hakuba
has no fan of another rook appearing on
a date okaygo screen b8 himself
preparing to take on before with the
Queen clean would show up and d4
probably position is kind of getting
worse for white yeah I tend to I tend to
agree this this looks quite nice for
black there's still this nagging
pressure on the f3 pawn and now he's
also threatening to invade on the
Queen's side it's going to be very very
difficult for white to deal with both
yeah but for the moment we do actually
have Alexander Linderman ready to come
in to talk about his game today talks
about his tournament on the whole it'll
be very interesting to hear his thoughts
alright so let's go there let me take a
look the first few moves of the Alex
Slenderman game Knight f3 Knight f6 a
Petrov which became extremely popular
after the Carlsen Caruana matches and
Lenderman follows their footsteps
in fact Knight c3 I have a feeling that
Alex kind of predicted Knight c3 to show
up on the board as Ilyas Marin is no
stranger to combative chess
so Knight c3 D takes Bishop e7 Bishop f4
which is interesting as most of the
times the players go Bishop e3 instead
of Bishop f4 so Bishop f4 is less
popular these days
castles Queen d2 97 the point of Knight
d7 is to go Knights e5 f Knight d4
there'll be night II 6 ideas in the
positions so without further ado we have
Alec Slenderman in the seat thank you
for having me and I want to ask you did
you predict Elias Marin going Knight c3
no actually I was surprised by it
because typically he plays other lines
against the Petroff I mean his most
common is t45 Bishop d3 you know the
other main line and also he's played a
couple of side lines as well even
the ship see form of two so I didn't
really know what to expect but I was
actually one of the reasons I you know
played Petra was because he doesn't
typically play 93 but then it came so
okay so then I know that he probably
wanted me to play Knight of six instead
of Knight takes c3 because I played like
this recent leggins fabia to use
championship so okay he probably came
prepared concretely and wanted that
position risk-free but okay I took a
chance that I'll remember of my analysis
to concede three and I was kind of happy
to see Bishop a4 instead of Bishop e3
because okay it's not really the main
line but I since I didn't really
remember the theory and you know Cates I
wanted to fight so I was pretty happy
you know what the way he played an
opening and in fact I knew about this
move Bishop before interesting enough
because I played a young rising star
around 2100 in a small tournament and he
played this before against me and
actually I got a not such a good
position and I I barely won the game but
so I you know I didn't really remember
but I think I at least remember what I
did wrong in that game so I was kind of
avoiding that at least and then of
course I was very pleasantly surprised
that I pretty sure I could just win the
porn out of the opening which I guess it
just goes to show that even in quiet
position there could be unexpected
tactics yeah it's very interesting
because whenever I see this structure I
know that this is going to be a Sicilian
like game where everyone is trying to
check me the other no one I was very
happy with that because obviously in
this station 50% is nothing special no
big difference between -1 and 50 so I
was hoping that you would go for some
kind of a fight which thankfully he did
yes yes Marin never disappoints if we
talk about fights yeah
97 castle Knights e5 and I don't know if
my observation is correct but would you
go Knight II 6 or that's not the plan if
like those 94 yeah I mean I guess if he
wants to by 94 maybe he should play it
here mom I'm not a hundred percent sure
what exactly I would do I mean I have
many choices I can still play rook e8
but then of course she plays a three he
gets that move in I mean 96 maybe
something I could have considered but
I'm pretty sure I wouldn't have played
Bishop f6 because I remember that's what
I did in the other game and the bishop
was kind of misplaced there staring with
the point on c3 so I was considering
between c65 or maybe a 6 b5 at some
point so I wasn't really sure I couldn't
remember the details I was just trying
to play logical chess I'm really curious
about this move f3 so is this preparing
the classical English attack or is this
a defensive move I mean little bit of
both I think I guess defending against
94 jumps or although now that I think
about it maybe he played King b1 because
uh you know i-96 let's say Bishop e3
Knight takes Bishop takes there's some
Bishop g5 ideas and maybe he was trying
to do prophylaxis seconds that's
somewhere something I mean okay I don't
think it's such a big deal anyway but
but maybe he was scared of that yeah I
mean wanted to avoid that King b1 Buki 8
it kind of reminds me of Geary games
when these rookie 8 moves come rookie it
seems to be always a useful move in the
pet reform or like from what I know yeah
yeah and here it looks like if I'm not
mistaken 94 is already a blunder high
and I mean I I saw that movement and I
thought ok I'll please go 94 and the
omission of 6 but in a sudden as so I
have miss pitch for and am I just not
much better and it was definitely a
pleasant surprise and if I go Bishop c4
what I was thinking about this should be
6 here mm-hmm just trying to neutralize
yeah I'm not sure how it yeah probably
with Nydia yeah Quan can become a little
bit loose ya know I thought I should be
close to equal mhm but I was pretty
happy I mean position would full of
fight yeah nothing to really complain
about the black yeah so 94 but then here
comes Knight e4 and I mean I don't know
if I missed something better but I mean
no I mean I'm pretty sure best pitch
force correct yes but I mean I saw of
course he could play this should be 5
but and I saw at least I can you know
have an opponent position but I was
wondering whether I missed something
better after a bit early 5 where I can
just win outright but I could see yeah
it is still kind of like this does look
like a very simple position
at least at first glance yeah no I saw I
could not at least call Bishop d7 but
what I'm saying this whether I missed
anything even even better than that I
mean that's yeah that's the big question
but it does seem that this looks like a
free pawn well it is a free pawn but of
course I'd at that moment I was a little
too greedy I was trying to see if I can
just you know base we're not right yeah
what yeah because of unfortunately if
night of two than g3 and let's say night
61 when I take such ones similar GH even
if I go c5 unfortunately he couldn't go
Knight b3 where the night is not under
attack going back if c4 yeah yeah
exactly and I couldn't make it work so I
guess I did what I had to something to
and after this was it still a game or it
was no absolutely it was a game I mean
from an OP opponents by no means
guarantee a mean but but I felt like the
way he was trying to defend she was
trying to defend by really creating
counter play and kind of go home all out
and especially like what did he do here
even c4 yeah so this was the decision
which I mean of course he could try to
defend possibly try to hold long game
and maybe that was objectively better
but it looks like yeah he wasn't really
in the mood for a long defense of
sovereign so he tried to go for this c4
GC takes takes Queen i5 and here I'm
again I'm not sure if I missed some
easier win but I'm what I think I
thought what I went for was also pretty
strong so but yeah yeah I mean you put
some pressure on the right yeah because
of Queen b7 there was an important bind
Queen b7 let's say 92 check this [ __ ] XD
to see text e to room do you want and
here
Queen h5 it's an important move because
the Frog Tex did too I have Quinn d1
this is very beautiful so that's you
know that yeah so that means like you
couldn't take the pawn and that means at
the very least I'm still up a pawn is
king this weekend but no here he you
know he found obviously good defensive
moves which don't lose right away and
again I couldn't figure out whether I
had something yet more convincing but I
thought this endgame is
and I mean eventually you did find this
one out I I did although at one moment I
actually missed a few things I mean he
found some very good defenses for
example let's keep going okay
a 93 here 92 here
rooty 5y and here King B 3 night of four
yeah and here she found a good move c3
because if he goes King c-4 than room D
- it's much easier witness but I didn't
see he can play c3 and the idea is of
course positional if he takes it has
this apron which is annoying counter
play maybe I'm winning but of course
it's very annoying yeah it's no reason
to give that so I played rock t3 Bishop
c5 rooks e3 King here 95 Kings king b5
rooks see - and hear a cow blue this
beautiful raishin suddenly it dawned on
me he can play king c6 and I'm like oh
man you know it's this king c6 just did
i just mess up but then of course
luckily for me I had this night of four
and I'm still winning in all the lines
but I'll tell you the truth the ayah I
almost feel like I messed this up but I
guess I didn't raking news Darrow's
where it's won his game and also tied
for second place
alright so king c6 metaphor and but now
you could go for this end game and this
is just yeah Sierra was 99% sure I was
winning the only thing is don't you know
mr. Shimizu says we should be 6 because
then you're not gonna sleep well after
no I remember I was I was fighting in a
similar kind of position I remember I
watched my friend play like a local like
rapid game he was playing a master and
he was on something like 1800 and that
was this one idea the master had and he
just you know played like h5 quickly and
the house yeah that's a heartbreak but
thankfully you didn't miss that one you
know so how do you feel about your
tournament overall well I was unhappy
with your quality of chess oh I mean I
think I mean what can I say I mean
obviously after a very heartbreaking
loss to a rare Robson and you know to
tell the truth I also had missed
opportunities early round in the
tournament also so basically the first
half was
very very difficult for me because I had
these great positions pretty much every
game and I more or less had nothing to
show for it and you know after that I
knew I'm probably not winning the
tournament um so at that moment it was
more like fine-tuning my game before I
love men you know my next big tournament
so I was wasn't really playing for the
result after you know after the lost
array I was just trying to play chess
and try to battle as much as I could and
obviously at this point you know the way
the term finished you know always
winning the last game makes sweeter and
you know certainly time for second is
much better than I could have expected
after you know very god punching lost
array I mean no I mean I was pressing
the whole game and you know that was
basically the you know the game I think
that won the raid the tournament is like
I think basically the break
turning point of the whole tournament
but at least I'm happy that I didn't
collapse I still played decent shots are
very important as we've seen from even
the leaders in both group anytime they
lost they stood up and fought and they
fought and it gave them the tournament
result yeah my game right after that
wasn't great but at least you know I had
a nice save against one forest from a
tough position I got a bit lucky there
yesterday I thought I played a very good
game but you know it wasn't quite enough
my opponent defended well an unpleasant
end game but today I guess I got some
luck because my opponent made a quick
mistake in the opening which I guess was
a was a gift so no all in all I mean
obviously very salt finished to my
tournament I mean overall I can't really
complain but of course clearly after
this turn I realized lots to work on
because to spoil so many good positions
is really unacceptable if I really want
to play at a very high level so so well
at least you won the last game and with
that I wish you all the best and I love
men thank you very much Wolff you'll
have a great tournament there thank you
very much yeah so we heard also that
Denis Cade rich has drawn his game
against Aram Hawk Obion also we have a
result in the cobia
game as a kobe on one against Alex
epitaph so we are going to take a look
we left off as a COPI on played Bishop
c2 in the pots of kind of agreed with me
and Caleb that this Bishop on c6 is not
doing much so let's just give this pawn
away Knight takes d4 I mean first
encounter play this okay five hoping to
double and just have some sort of play
not sure if it's enough but at least
it's a try Ruki three okay and rook b3 a
very nice little maneuver defending this
b4 night planning some Knight d5
discovery yeah I didn't want to jump in
these are actually some surprising
results we've just got yeah the course
bar did have a very nice position and
we're seeing now how he converted that
but I'm also especially surprised that
around Hagopian drew so quickly with
Dennis CAD rich but we should finish
looking at bars result first but that
was kind of crazy to meet Dennis getting
away with murder there so Queen a 7h
five and as Caleb already mentioned if
white ever gets the free time to attack
on the H line then Henrik will do the
business take away that h7 blockade er
and it's gonna be checkmate and guess
what
that's what happened Bishop a4 takes
takes ninety five and white doesn't care
about exchanges anymore of course not
it's all about that King it's all about
the king the King the king b6 e six
Bishop g7 c7 and black decided decided
that it's over because after Queen d7
boom you would give away the rook takes
check you here and not f6 is not J every
day double Chinese
check me yes check double check check
mates
Royal Fork very nice lime can bar
they're calculating all that really
earning his share of the second place
prize as well we're up to three players
sharing second place in the egg group
but why don't we take a look at this
position where Rama Cobian agreed to a
draw with Dennis Kendrick it's a little
bit shocking to me actually to be honest
with you I think it has to do with the
tournament situation yeah as Huckabee I
knew that he's not going to catch up
with Yasser Quezada right so he decided
that okay a draw is not tragic and I
wouldn't want to fight too hard for this
extra point
yeah extra health I want five and a half
likely going to be enough for a second
place anyways yes but would have been
nice to see around play a little bit
more chest here try a little bit harder
in this Aram was definitely better and
could have pressed for a victory but
felt that there's no need to go for that
in this position all right that leaves
us with most of the relevant games
actually completed in both sections
there are actually just two games left
still still playing let's take a look at
the other key game and for the B group
the Miha left's quiche then bully out
game sounds good to me what's going on
here
it's gotten crazy so let's back it up
where every last laughed at off yeah we
were expecting a some type of line where
white pushes the H pawn it and black
rounds up the C and the G pawn in
exchange the expected book the three
butts temple the accident what the
players that actually went for the
assembly I decided to bring the King
closer maybe sends a good idea makes
sense but Bishop eight-six probably a
little inaccurate possibly pushing the
pawns was more precise by Michael FC but
we can't really blame him as he was
under severe time trouble Russia played
six King e6 rookie f3 and on the other
hand these pawns yet to move to g4 and
g5 where this Bishop would be a great
support of course and this is the moment
for stamboli act to stop this pawn you
often see these motive and bancos you go
rook g8 and you stop this pawn from
moving to g4 and this Bishop cannot
really help the pawns from moving
forward Bishop d2 e for of course you
know for taking advantage of the the
color complex that the bishop cannot
control yeah the light squares King g5
Ian he this is kind of a banker's
position where this Knight is much
stronger than this Bishop and this rook
is more active than this rook on f4 and
therefore even though White has the
connected past bonds
excuse me it's very difficult to make
head base with white yeah I definitely
agree here
looking at looking more and more like a
draw however I did want to mention one
position well the only other position is
actually looking a little bit more
interesting than we first gave it credit
for we mentioned that the only way for
white to break through in this mill coup
Mian bortnik game was going to be if he
sacrificed a piece yes and we sounded
skeptical but he's gone he's done it and
it's looking quite nice for him now
yeah
disaster are you ok Dennis I hope so
ok I hope so see it we last last left
off somewhere around here so here
Malcolm young because of the situation
and determined or just being ambitious
in general decided to go for the
sacrifice yes of course Bishop takes a
five and after B takes a five rook takes
a five black is up a full knights and
the light squared bishop for the dark
squared bishop but now these rooks are
actually going to be able to penetrate
for white and so yeah what's going on
here what what did the players end up
playing it looks like rook b7 defending
this night and after Bishop f7 a very
nice tactic the rook has to be
distracted from its defense of the night
or else
of course these g6 and h5 punts would
also fall so Rick takes f7 rook takes b6
check and now all the pressure is on
black his extra piece this Bishop on f8
does not make a good impression
yes meanwhile White's rooks are very
active very dangerous even creating some
checkmating threats but as we look at
Malcolm young we can see that he's still
not entirely certain if he's going to
break through at all yeah I I think he's
cautiously optimistic as these players
often honest he doesn't see that the
knock out just yet
but he knows he probably should never
lose this position well you can imagine
it could happen but probably his
position is just fine he just needs to
find the right way to shift these pieces
around to try to make something happen
mm-hmm yeah it's a good question though
still if he's going to manage to win
this he is the one pressing but this
Bishop is doing a good job defending
these key squares definitely so bortnik
has all and every reason to hope to
survive this game
well let's play some moves of course for
white I want to keep as many wrecks on
the board as possible yes that my
interest lies so I want to start with
rook v eh6 and then what my black do
here at rook co then I would run into
this guy yes this is my idea I want to
push this pawn forward and then deliver
my shoes checkmate run before it's too
late okay King c8 seems like a
reasonable try and now I was wondering
how can I make progress
I wanted to play I don't know if it's
good don't make fun of me I want to play
c5 at the right moment and if you were
to take this pawn I bring my king up to
see for a very nice square and the point
is I've opened up this sixth rank I have
a lot of threats coming against your
jeep on and if I can make three passed
pawns
maybe then that will be enough to us
yeah good point good point
and in fact even though this bishop is a
good defender and it does defend these
key squares it's still super passive yes
of course and it can't really fight
against rooks if it comes down to it no
yeah when every rooks and bishops get
into fights my money is usually on the
rook yeah the rook is a heavy guy hard
to deal with them um yeah so this does
look more unpleasant for like and maybe
it's even more pleasant than I thought
it was yeah this Rick be a six move you
still got some problems
yeah this looks and the c5 King c-4 plan
looks very annoying yeah one line that I
wasn't sure about Rick ba6 let's say
King c8 like you first intended
and now after c5 the other move that you
have to check is rook takes b5 rather
than Pontic see so I might check you and
go c6 yes this uh this looks dangerous
yeah do I have time to just play King c7
and try to jet try to jet to my home
wait mmm
hop in my my private airplane and get on
out of there
good question I might want to see you go
back okay do I have to go back well do
you dare go forward now I better go back
I'll go back at it go back but then I
take the 7th and that looks like the end
is nigh a lot of threats coming towards
this black King it's going to be
interesting to see a what a black comes
up with or if if white white is really
thinking about this move I wonder what
else he could be considering besides
moving this this burek to a sixth seems
like the only way to keep his advantages
well to be honest with you rook c6 is a
also an idea right and then try to go c5
and King c4 that's also an option okay
also this rook would be like double
defendant would be placed pretty well on
c6 as well so look c6 is an option but
maybe will be a six is more logical but
I don't like about Rick c6 is I gets
black this extra option to play rook a7
and now I'm not sure if I'm ever going
to get my other rook into the game and
if I trade off one set of rooks I think
my winning chances really start to go
down on the other hand I might be still
able to go over their plan and bringing
the king up and do the same thing and
this rook is still very passive yep I
just I like all these positions with
with that extra hook on the board yeah
that's true it's nicer to have the extra
rook okay so this game looking Pleasant
for white but we'll have to give him a
few minutes I think to determine what
he's actually going to be doing but I
believe we have var a Kobe in here ready
to talk about his big win today and his
tournament overall yes that's full of
that game yeah that goodly and I just
get out of my chair here and let var
join us yes
so after some very funky moves by black
we reach some sort of Kings Indian kind
of position the night
not necessarily optimally placed on a
six h3e five and in fact black is
getting into a position where you would
not want to play C 6 but C 6 has already
been played so but why would I explain
this to you when we have our Akopian
here the winner of this game and what do
you think do you think night a 6 C 6 is
kind of an early concession in this type
of structure I think it's it was
playable position I don't think I had
that much that big of an advantage I was
slightly better but I know Alex he likes
to play this unorthodox opening she
actually wrote a book on it on all the
sidelines and you know very interesting
book last year and I I just just
realized I just need to play a normal
chest and I quite liked how I played
this game except at one point I think I
just let my advantage slip away I think
this is fine everything Queen d2 they
more or less normal Blanco so and I mean
normally black would love to go a6 b5
but it's hard to the 1986 yeah it's
there's some problems with this six
phone here as well so I think you played
to find a rook e8
and yeah I think he he rushed here with
d5 so he told me he underestimated my
idea of capture capture if I which is
just a tactical idea because he cannot
take only five Bishop takes a6 and if
you take knight c6 and now I pick up the
exchange and if he takes rook e3 which
is I think another important detail
because sometimes in this position black
can actually sacrifice the exchange like
if I just take acted if if if let's say
this position I take he would have some
compensation but it's very concrete
because he takes only six and I have 96
mhm
so I mean time to get rid of one of the
bishops at least I just want to get rid
of one Bishop and then I go
the one I think it's attack it's not
that strong anymore so yeah I felt
really good about my position I don't
know what the engine evaluation is I
thought I wasn't agree it was close to
be winning I know but maybe I'm not I'm
wrong so he played the 97th and another
idea just to mention wine ith fire
doesn't work here you know Bishop takes
a six and takes g4 and 93 and tonight
it's just tonight d7 f4 and actually
it's interesting that in many of these
Kings Indian positions a five is not a
typical also sometimes you have this
idea CD CD C files it's like you change
the positional approach here now I don't
have this because then I get something
but it's but usually work before ya take
ya I don't know here I think I have a
large advantage here I'm not sure if I
play the best by Ted King we won here I
wanted to get my King out of the way
then he played it's very hard for black
to move here it just his position is
these Knights are just so awkward and
coordination is bad and so take Queen f8
I pay g4 I don't know I think it's a
good move to stop this bishop at five
ideas forever so then he played Bishop
d7 96 there might have been other
possibilities as well but okay Bishop c6
took yeah here here I made it in
accuracy here so I think we should be
six is correct and I was doing it just
Knight takes d5 here mm-hmm
just 95 a minute yeah yeah I mean
because of these pieces so out of place
yeah next was Bishop c4 yeah Bishop c4
and this looks so there's no most
decisive night c5 he has to play and I
somehow forgot about this Bishop I saw
Bishop c4 now I thought he has b5
everything forgot I can just take back
mmm and I'm just up to pause any attack
yeah yeah yeah I actually overlooked
this room d6 idea this room d6 was a
very good try for him so meanwhile the
malevsky stand bull dr game ended in a
drop but let's go back to this yeah so
this route d6 is a very resourceful idea
by all
I think now it's not so clear because if
I take I overlooked this idea I thought
actually if you go back a second I was
just gonna point out I thought he's just
gonna take back with the beat take say I
go Knight takes d5 and I go - okay Siwon
and I mean strong knights even though I
give up my vicious but yeah that's a
very strong yeah so then he played this
and now it's it's it's unclear I haven't
tried to win this all over I think I'm
only slightly better here but I like how
I played I think I played quite well
from here on despite being a little bit
long time consolidate my musician
getting out of any potential racial
tricks you had a tree support I have
some f5 ideas here so he needs to watch
for that idea yes now he wants to do
some g5 maybe at some point or f6 out I
said you know I'm gonna shut that down
yeah and not just Bishop is completely
dead
the problem is pawns are quiet week so
if he doesn't succeed in attacking me
then in the long run his pawns are quite
weak and I have this now h4 h5 plum
which i think is very straightforward
and that's how I think I guess this is
important yes yes this is very important
defensive move stopping the before
planted very hard to attack here and
even though he had a lot of time but he
couldn't come up with ideas maybe you
should play d4 I think here I mean we
already hated on this bishop in the
commentary and it does make sense - I
think white is better here but I was
kind of long time I thought this was his
chance here but he sacrificed the pawn I
think right yeah Bishop c2 is another
important move by the way to cover the a
Foursquare no so not a lot okay 444
thank you take and another important
move rookie 3 this work is just coming
to b3 just to cement the deviance yes
there is not going to be any attack on
the a Falcons you just have done a b4
night I like this rookie three move
ahead like actually six seconds well
yeah no that was a very nice yeah and
now I just go into now it's just
crushing and it's a very nice finish and
so now it's a pretty little cage service
yes this is
double-check discovered check oil fork
everything meaning the house a very nice
game Commission's thank you yeah so I
wanted to ask how do you feel after this
tournament uh well I actually started
well I drew my first three games and
some chances there and then I wonder
game four against the adios
was a Guam playing quite well because I
haven't played since us championship
over the board I played some protest
League games for Archbishop's yes but I
haven't played over the board so I
wasn't sure when you don't play for five
months you don't know what performance
so and then I had this two unfortunate
games I lost to smearing in a much
better position then I had kind of a bad
game against Ray I didn't play that well
that game and I was like oh that's too
office in a row but then I had this wild
game with Malcolm young I managed to
survive and draw and then I want to lost
to mmm so the finish was really good I
won yesterday and today so looks like
it's gonna be a shirt second place so
overall I'm satisfied with the result
but I think just the losses were so I
guess there's still always room for
movement but still a decent distance
plus one
yeah I should be gaining okay some
rating points as well so it's it's good
to be back playing decent chance you
know congratulations thank you hopefully
you'll get another good tournament
recognition so so let's take a look at
the switch Dhirubhai League game cuz we
missed the end right there Bishop takes
six takes King g7 King g1 a star move
just as big of a star move as VARs
Knight a two which basically killing him
that game and share the second place a
bishop c8 was played still trying to
fight but it's very difficult to fight
as these rooks are very quick and this
King is a bit too much out in the open
so Queenie for true--but and g4 and I
think this also deserves full marks you
want to block this bishop you don't want
to give any sorts of counter chances
when you're up stunting the bishop and
now
the rest is easy the Rex I imagine so
Bishop e7 rook f1 and after the rook
survive it's game over
yes of course sir cows having a nice
tactic you do not get rook and Bishop
against Queen but rather after Queen f7
rook F seven king f7 there's Queen h7
check picking up that bishop as well and
that in game would be hopeless despite
what Amman Hambleton has tried to show
and a couple of his games but with that
in mind there is just one game remaining
in the entirety of the fall chess
classic and that is this game between
Mel cumin and bortnik why don't we and
this is your day stop into the last is
your day it's my day everybody
everybody follows Caleb's advice I like
it yeah maybe it looks said c5 and King
c-4 in what are you going to do this is
my plan and Malcolm you said I couldn't
agree more
all right well Matt you get so many fans
these days you know what tennis I'm
really trying I'm trying good but happy
to hear that not all of my commentary is
complete nonsense and every once in a
while I suggest a move that gets played
with none of Mines it's going to be very
tough for black here right yes it's
going to be tough and it's a practical
game it's not that easy to make the only
only moves of course but you know black
is definitely going to be thinking here
for a while and with that in mind we are
running a little bit short on time today
since this is the last game I think we
better hear one final time from the
wonderful Ryan Chester about a golden
opportunity for you
in the st. Louis chess club we are
promoting the Golden Tickets and he's
going to tell you all about it
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck what a wonderful
opportunity and a one from the money
support chess in schools and get
yourself a chance for some big money as
well definitely an opportunity that you
do not want to miss with that in mind
though the fall chats classic is just
about wrapped up why don't we take a
final look at these standings in the B
group first of all am on Hamilton
unfortunately only one out of nine
definitely a tournament that he would
like to forget
I think the tournament for him to forget
and hopefully evoke bounce back in his
very next tournament it does go to show
how tough this tournament is how strong
the field is and you know how dangerous
things can be if you're just all form
Steven Zurich on three and a half he had
a bit of an up-and-down tournament he
played some very nice games but just
enough unfortunate games as well that
just didn't go his way
Alexander fear one of the group's most
fighting chess players the King Gamma
tier finishing on four out of nine not a
bad score a better Gregorian another
player up and down tournament played
some very nice games had some very
unfortunate losses four out of nine not
a bad score as well Victor McCleskey on
four and a half out of nine scoring 50%
again really interesting chess games
from almost all of these players that is
CAD rich the spoiler of the events tried
to spoil a few players chances and was
actually succeeded quite well in and
knocking down this Jackson Bulli ACK
former Group B leader a man what
petrosyan five-and-a-half and shared
second place with a win in the final
rounds
of course I believe he was actually
paired against Amon Hamilton who did not
appear in this time around there I'm on
unfortunately forfeited his game yes
around Maccabean injection booyah both
drew they're around nine results
bringing them to five and a half out of
nine and then finally your group beat
champion yes or case out of there is
leaving no doubt in anyone's mind that
he deserves the victory even winning his
final round game unnecessarily well but
showing true grit yes
to close this tournament outright
because if he would have drawn you can
be sure that the chasers wouldn't have
back down of course
definitely a closer than it may seem
looking at these final scores he walks
away with the grand prize of $4,000 big
congratulations - yes - nation's air
valve done yeah a very well-played
tournament and then why don't we take a
look at where we stand in the a group
olexander bortnik is still fighting
against Ronald cumin in his game other
than that Alexander epitaphs and
received er by Lee finished on three and
a half out of nine especially for the
seif kind of a turnaround he wasn't
hoping for BC was actually off to an
early lead in this tournament but things
kind of just slipped from there Ilyas
smearin played some very interesting
chess in in these nine rounds defeating
some really big names in group a but so
falling in some positions were perhaps
you know he he had more chances than a
he was true to his style and sometimes
sometimes mixing up that like going for
more positional play maybe would have
suited his chances in this tournament
more interesting frontal kuhnian is
fighting actually for a chance at a
shared second place prize against
Alexander Zbornak of course that is the
last game remaining and he has already
sacrificed a piece in that game and is
hoping to grind out a very technical
endgame now Jordan been forced
unfortunately was just a couple minutes
too late for his round today
of course after 30 minutes the players
are automatically forfeited if they have
not yet shown up to the board and Jordan
was something like I don't know 33 34
minutes late and your then did show some
very fine efforts in this tournament it
definitely played solidly playing
quality chess and it's kind of
unfortunate that he couldn't make the
round as he was here guaranteed to be in
the tie for a second even though he
couldn't catch ray Robson at that moment
anymore absolutely and then three
players tied for second of course they
might be joined by a fourth player front
mill commune Alexander Lenderman Darras
roots vara Cobian I'll really get it
done in this final round today
winning their three games and deserving
their share of the second place prize
definitely props to them as winning on
them in the last round on order is
always a great achievement yes very
difficult stuff and then last but
certainly not least your group
a champion is Grandmaster Ray Robson
winning five games in a row in the
middle of the tournament a truly
astounding feat by Ray he walks away
with the first-place prize of six
thousand dollars a truly magnificent way
of bouncing back after a painful defeat
against taro spirits where he played
decently but then swears fought his way
back into the game and eventually
defeated him but that didn't really stop
ray from winning five games
consecutively
and that's a true sign of a champion
definitely ray bouncing back showing his
grit showing his chest skills and
winning this group a championship this
will be a very good practice tournament
for him for the upcoming candidates Open
tournament and I love men definitely
well Dennis it's been a pleasure
commentating with you over this ball
chess classic we'd like to thank all of
you viewers for joining us for this
conclusion to the summer of chess now
fortunately I think everybody at the
Chess Club
needs a little bit of a break from all
of these tournaments these incredible
tournaments but we will be back for the
Super bet rapid and blitz starting in
November November 6th that will start
and also be on the lookout for a few
smaller events going on at the Chess
Club a few fun a few casual events I
believe for you might come ur fans out
there you might be seeing a very
interesting tournament in October but
decided to hear about it other than that
any final thoughts on this tournament
I'm very impressed with the fighting
spirit in both sections and I love the
fact that no setback could stop any of
the players they knew okay I lost this
game doesn't matter I'll move on let's
go let's look straight into the future
and let's try to do our best and as
you've seen in the case of Lenderman
Robson yasser Quezada Peres sometimes
you have to look straight forwards and
do your best in the upcoming games and
you might end up winning five games
consecutively yes
perseverance in the story of your 2019
all chess classic but with that in mind
we'd like to thank you all once again
for joining us for watching thank you
for watching and we will not see you
next time this is this is it for us this
is it and thank you for joining us in
the 2019 ball chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you